hey guys this is dennis offender think
here mom david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the walking dead season
4 finale hey ah so both you and me have
been kind of critical of this season
however i thought this season actually
ended pretty well i like the finale it's
it wasn't the best walking dead episode
ever but i thought it was pretty good
and stuff actually happened i thought
even though the season was very slow at
times actually a good amount of time you
know that at least these last few
episodes act something actually happened
yeah it was good i mean in for you know
said as a reader of the comic books I'd
really didn't know was going to happen
some of the stuff with the hunters or
whatever I kind of knew that side of
things but like last over the terminus
at the end I didn't know so it left me
in suspense this was one of the better
episodes of the season for sure Shotwell
it opening shadow Frick just bloody and
shaking was was cool i really enjoyed
the flashbacks you know it's seeing
Herschel again which I said really like
that actor who plays her so sweet I
personally didn't care for the
flashbacks oh yeah I just didn't think I
didn't think they were necessary I
didn't mind them they weren't bad I
didn't think they needed to be there the
making of a direction Michelle Maclaren
I think her name yeah Breaking Bad yeah
she's worked some of the best breaking
bad episode yeah so she directed this
episode was written by a the showrunner
Scott Gimple and uh Angela King I think
king or cone yeah I someone producers
you so yeah I really liked this episode
because stuff actually happened I mean
first you know let's let's start off I
mean most of the episode 99 percent of
it is just it is Rick Michonne Carl hmm
and so I like that I like how in the
beginning we saw them really hungry cuz
that's yeah it would be the
post-apocalyptic world I kind of was
critical i think i'm in season one or
two where water and food and ammo seems
so like abundance everywhere and now
they've come to a place where oh they
actually are thirsty and hungry and they
got to see a
save their ammo right that's one thing
I've always appreciate about walking
dead and you know I have talked about
this about how let's say a show like
revolution an NBC not to hate you know
love eric kripke loves supernatural but
um everybody so pretty they got like the
nice hair and the gap clothes and you're
looking like models whereas walking it
has always been dirty gritty I do
appreciate it asked by people do look I
guess authentic as you wouldn'ta
post-apocalyptic well I've never
experienced one before I mean I think
they look authentic but yeah the look of
this was great against Michelle Maclaren
did such a great job shooting it I got
it walking did for me has never been an
issue with the way it's been shot I
think it's just living in this world
it's so dark it's so sad it's post
apocalypse there's zombies I understand
that I think the difference for me I'm
not comparing the story with the books
what I'm saying is with the comics I
read once a month I read it for what 15
minutes I'm done I think hour after hour
week after week with the show I think
starting to weigh on me a little bit
just emotionally like I just it's just
so dark and dour all the time but I did
appreciate this episode in the way which
how this for me was one of the better
episodes oh hey I give credit where
credit's due this was a good episode for
me for me it's not how dark the show is
it's just more there's no hope and that
doesn't bother me I've got to have some
hope add doesn't know or like The Land
Before Time where's the Great Valley you
got to have some hope for me it's more
about just them stretching out the story
I mean this is what a 13-episode season
yeah they had seven or eight episodes
worth of story yeah they just stretched
out and that's why I think these last
few episodes have been really good
because they knew they were ending the
season so they saved all this story for
the a mystery so stuff actually happened
the last few episodes where it didn't
always before right okay go to go back
to the flash but I kind of wanted to
defend those a little bit I actually
enjoyed the flashbacks because I think
they were showing even though maybe it
was already too obvious anyway they were
showing Rick losing his humanity I wish
now again not to compare the comic books
you see Rick and his son Carl loser he
many together I think he did a better
job especially with the whole thing with
the two girls and the killing the girl
Carl's more involved in that story in
the books you see they're losing their
humanity together after Rick stabbed
that guy like 15 20 times how many times
he
abdom like he just lost his humanity I
think you go back and you see at that
time we had with herschel and he was
like you know like this could work we're
farming we're happy but I love it Rick
said in that moment he said you know
what today is a good day and that's
enough for now we're source was like it
can always be like this which is just
not realistic but Rick was realistic and
said look today's a good day let's just
live in that and let's live in this good
day yeah like I said I didn't hate the
flashbacks from me they were just
unnecessary because I already know you
know yeah like I I when I see a scene
like that with Rick and all that stuff I
know what it was like before already
right idea did it really like that scene
when we know they get ambushed yeah and
Darrell's with that group because I
thought that scene had a lot of tension
to it it was good yeah where you're like
oh my god I mean you know in your head
like you know they can't die right right
what if one of them does you know you
don't know like Rick could die or Carl
they're not be Darryl though you go
there oh Darrell goes people stop
watching the show now um that was a
great scene I don't know why you know he
just didn't go go say claimed way that's
a whole hunter away like you claim
something that's yours he shoulda just
said claim oh I'm so glad that that that
crap is over with ya know they got him
and that was I mean Rick we know Rick's
a badass we have to see him Rick's been
kind of mopin lately he's been hurt he
was sick so if I see him ripa guys throw
it out you know with his teeth you know
he's tough rick is tough he's easy sure
he's just he was just shaken I was
waiting for him he's like The Incredible
Hulk like you're not gonna like me when
I'm angry so that was that was a good
seemed like when the gun went off and he
couldn't hear anything and it was good
it was well shot scene yeah and it's you
know you gotta do what you gotta do I
mean when you know it that guy was
trying to rape his son yeah I was
Robert's going crazy I think it scared
Carl a little bit ya hear cause like wow
dad's psycho no scary yeah but I mean
considering the situations yeah I don't
blame him yeah Michonne being the mother
figure to him you know he's she's heat
Carl's lying in his lap and she's like
not gonna lie I kind of want to see him
a show on Rick relationship ah wouldn't
mind seeing that I don't know what's
gonna happen which was a little hard but
I gotta wanna kind of one mind seeing
that yeah me got the you know the father
the mother the Sun daryl is kind of like
the big brother yeah
uh-huh well actually not the big brother
he's more like the uncle right he's like
the uncle right um so I mean it was good
i mean i like I mean I guess I think
this episode maybe I had to go back it's
might be one of my favorite episode okay
cuz episode with me when with Carol and
the girls and you know the whole the
with the flowers like that didn't really
do it for me but this episode i really
liked i felt i did feel a connection
with like you said like it's almost a
family dynamic with the mother the
father and then Darrell's like the Big
Brother I really liked this episode yeah
and then they get to terminus and you
know we had speculated before not like
it was anything you know like a people
reishi over there yeah like we knew
something was gonna be up iris they're
not gonna have a place where Oh
everything's look for to quiet over
there to two nite the people are too
nice everything's too easy right so yeah
we find out that there they have
captured Maggie and Glenn and the rest
of those guys um I was waiting for Carla
gets shot Oh what cuz I'm gonna call was
like out in the open like by I was
waiting for like when those guys you
should just shoot him I girls like me
look Armenian it just shows really good
direction it was a good suit it was
tension there was tension during that
scene yeah I like that seen to because
even as a person who doesn't really care
for the character no all right right I
still felt you know like oh my god you
could go to yeah he get shot so that was
good we got to see everybody is and Rick
says the famous line that's all over
tumblr and they were online is they've
screwed with the wrong people that are
something lino so that was a little
cheesy for the last little cheesy i mean
this cuz they're they're trapped in like
this thing and they have no weapons I'm
like a little too macho there right yeah
i mean he's doing his fame you know what
a one-liner ain't off like a back shun
movie or something so I mean that's
where we leave them but wishing the
seasons who are this finalis who we
didn't see you know Harry Tyrese hair
Judith yeah didn't see them so they're
out there somewhere do you think they
could come and save the day oh I don't
know that's two people I mean to give
the people credit they're Germans
they're pretty well organized like at
first when they were shooting I'm like
me this is the worst shooting people
I've ever seems like a Star Wars movie
but they were
writing them I mean they were actually
very well organized so it's going to be
tough for them to bring them down it's
gonna be no easy feat exactly that's why
I think we're uh trick maybe a little
bit too overconfident in in their
abilities to escape risk crazy right now
he sees in another place you know and
there's also speculation that these guys
are cannibals and they drop they will go
by that um area as much like human
remains and blood and you know and
they're like you know ladies frying
something up in the previous episode who
knows what she's cooked and they're
about to eat it and then they saw
Glenn's watchful Herschel's watch that I
gave Glenn all the other dried gear all
that night off right so people are crazy
yeah I would trust um so yeah I enjoyed
the episode I liked it and I you know
for me you know if Walking Dead was like
this all the time you know I you know I
be I think I'd be praising the show a
lot more it's just there's a lot of
episodes where you know nothing yeah
it's such a moneymaker for them and to
they don't have an end in sight you know
there's no like Game of Thrones
announcement like we're gonna go seven
seasons there is no you know lost after
what season three and yeah knowing like
hey we're ending after this story at six
seasons were ending well when you have
was a 15-point something million for the
season finale that's insane that's the
huge numbers that's like the second most
viewers they ever had and the first was
this year's season over yep premiere
it's just going bigger and bigger every
we name this is AMC's number one show
they're gonna put everything behind this
and make it last as long yeah which is
possible some people some of you said
and it's interesting to hear that you
wouldn't mind seeing the show go like 10
seasons and I think that's a little bit
much I don't think I want to see any
movie internet movie series go right
especially drama company okay maybe you
know cuz you're doing you know you know
22 minute episodes yeah I mean six seven
seasons is a lot for an hour long drama
it's like there's only so many stories
you can tell I think people creators
institutes are afraid to let go because
that's what that's their moneymakers
that can we create something else and
that can cause especially with AMC you
have you have that bensley madman's
ending Breaking Bad just
and a couple new shows but who knows
what those are exactly a low winter Sun
didn't do very well holy up so now what
do you have you know I don't think this
you know better call Saul is gonna do
very well no it's not gonna get these
kind of numbers know and I'll saidu war
movie coming out with jamie bell yeah it
looks interesting but i don't think
that's going to get 10 million viewers i
mean so yeah they're really gonna hold
on to their baby alright guys so that's
what we thought of the season four
finale of The Walking Dead you can post
your comments below on the website thing
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
hero pro make sure to subscribe to that
you also can find us on Twitter I'll
talk to Dennis or myself about the
walking dead maybe try to convince me of
why I should keep watching the show for
next season the last few episodes were
good they need to watch next to the
finale maybe entreat me to watch the
premiere of next season so I'll give it
a shot of you defy this epic hero i'm at
griffin de and we also a facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans make sure you like that page and
share our videos on facebook twitter and
anything else that will help us out
thanks
you